yep we got captions to work nice I'm so
happy about that
I'm going to make a video about that I don't
know how soon I'm going to make it to work
but I might just do it right now
oh shit I forgot to update my notification
on Twitch somebody thinks I'm playing
Witcher
that's sad I'm not not playing with her at
least not right now
let's do a video about it Amy has a question
you go ahead and go in the
and the questions area
you can actually tell me what you might want
to talk about going to be just doing in a
couple hours of Amy today I got up a little
bit later than usual just go from 12 to we
can go from 12 to 2 Wednesday at 2 on masoma
still I try to keep the schedule or try to
keep him a 1:49 in this first hour today and
took me to some other stuff later today but
I do when I get a couple couple
informational videos today based on stuff
that we did this week
so I'm going to go ahead and do that how you
doing Sarah Sullivan p
a needs a good brushing
I'ma go ahead and make that going to go
ahead and make this your real quick
so
for that I'm going to come in at the turn
off the sound when you make a video
he's my man house that casting
how's it going burani
I kind of already did one about it taking a
break at the song is pretty good
I think I kind of
I don't like doing this but I'm I'm going to
I'm going to do is I'm going to stop the
stream they going to make a video and then
I'll start shooting back up I won't keep it
will keep that about that so we can do the
recording thing you say I am
recording how to add
closed captioning twitch
I guess you capitalize that
yep multipass of KCBS on the way
or two workers okay
all right I'm going to I'm going to use the
vod's as that is a video has the video thing
so I will be I'll be back in 10 seconds